les amis du monde
voilà je vous le dis en fait on leur a
fait faire un truc on leur a dit qu'il
fallait dire joie de noël aux
téléspectateurs et je m'étais caché dans
un fossé
regardez bien les réactions sont
diverses avant de voir notre arrivée en
finlande
ces gens venus chez moi ok c'est bon
t'es pas cassation va donc tu te mets
par la belgique voilà ici léger voile et
ben là c'est en fait c'est pour la chef
du fai sait pas comment on est en
laponie 12,7 de noël salut à tous je
vous souhaite un très bon noël un joyeux
noël je suis en la police je suis prêt
du père noël pour tous vos messages
j'étais pas à me téléphona qu'on ait
peur
de là bas
à dupont annonce enfin des trucs comme
ça avec deux touches je te promets gp
américain je suis furieuse jusqu'à ce
noble exo arrête moi j'ai l'ambiance qui
peut être gaulle et matthieu delormeau
le toit
[Musique]
regardez ce que jean barbier un truc je
connais je vous connais je vous connais
ne fut pas vous déjà oui moi ouais tu
sors ton ami whaou étaient parés de
l'antenne alors j'ai ça j'avais à mes
débuts je pensais que ça donc moi je
sors mes toiles méthodes voilà merci bon
mathieu là là là là là ici un recul un
peu m voilà tu as regardé si tu regarde
ici mais après tu regardes les
regarderont donc vous un panier à
truquer match du genre mais c'est lui la
regarde quel sifflante et le bas c'est
pas de ma faute
le pauvre tiers ça depuis une heure et
demie les cas mathus a fait un truc mais
sous la dent mathieu mathieu noël à tous
ça veut dire quoi
c'est dire que nos fans 12 au niveau je
peux pas et qui comprend pas c'est quoi
l'histoire
cette annonce était latent mais venez
tous artistes au regard non mais
beaucoup et je vois là non non non je te
fais ce grand show de l'animateur en
elle-même
d'après des voix la fusée validation des
livres il rajaona de 10 m aulas
nettement le japon mais si besoin bah il
ne faut le faire bah tu fais un truc
rapide alors à ce moment pour le faire
un vieux jeu pas du tout la veille de
noël mais si hockey c'est la magie noël
tu regardes la food allez tu fais un
truc lescouët en touche environ 15 cm et
3 octobre
mais j'avais pas choisi web les mineurs
étant allés une heure je me dirais que
de plus on peut dire david maisel
cinésites hommage charge du ville me
laporte une redoutable jeu sans passion
mais tu pas du tout dans la vie active
stop animateurs attention trois ans avec
comme des amis
parker est jamais rien qu'il est dans le
rouge
à voir les missionnaires et laon du ja
on a coupé la clé comme la séquence a
duré une heure
je n'en pouvais plus c'est pourquoi
entraîné le truc pas bouger j'avais ça
rigolait il a perdu michinot c'est un
truc louche toi qui vas faire croire le
gars en a rien à [ __ ] de rien qui veut
rester là pour vérifier une bonne
annonce sur ce dvd live dit si on n'a
pas le choix d'être professionnel avec
van sant